packets but ii babble i guess and we're
playing rested lake hotel this is a new
game and for me it's actually been out
for years but i wanna play the sequel
rusty like roots but i don't play this
first okay he heard a lot of the music
chiana's kidding effects on attack okay
let's do this first you like hotel rusty
like 89 right ah get out that let me
introduce myself
okay my name is mister i am the owner
the guests are arriving the animals
that's where they all have their own
reasons to be here and i I have my own
reasons to let them stay okay we'll be
having five dinners make sure everyone
is worth dying for
I'm sure it's gonna be a wonderful week
let's make some memories very class I I
like it I like it
Bulai batting and I got that Jam
character oh I don't care take these bad
boys hello mister cry walk on that guess
that I'll tell okay okay where the guess
no yeah right go here sorry
thank you but I'm more I'm 8% that's
okay yeah now a shrimp cocktail bars up
ah this smells that fresh eh yeah but
yeah Matt hi mr. Barr yeah yeah I go
black that's all I know is that very sad
yeah mr. rabbit you killed my friend in
another again I'm looking fat that's
okay all right Bechet knock that out
I don't hate pink what's in here I had
to prefer the dinner first
the lab' wait I can't take that red ring
rumor
she's gonna do a room okay anyway I'm
gonna talk this guy mr. growl uh Sara
didn't look I did I did that kitchen and
there then I guess are either hey Beth
yeah thigh right in here to get fresh
ingredients see the recipes in the menu
okay deer steak with mushrooms and
rosemary optional do you make raspberry
okay yeah got it sister was that blood
okay back to the lobby miss rosemary
never here
no sorry
yeah everything you know say I dead
walked on them it stars me
ah mr. Howell I hear you on this place
case back
you're now out there on the roads at any
time can I get that ahead for the first
dinner tomorrow
are you need the nightfall to guess go
to their rooms at the lobby let's go an
Amish that crab what to light us can't
see if you can help the guests in there
I thought I can't go there room yes
Oh stupid cat I'm on Tara
okay Ramon
yes I need the venison right mr. tears
of research plan attack now yeah yeah by
tech hey man thank you
Bloody Mary blood vodka Tabasco special
ingredient I say I say could I make him
a Bloody Mary hello miss it there
read me a Bloody Mary can I get a vodka
was it's a perfect okay we're gonna get
a blood from oh great a punch-up moths
ate I'm gonna say ate someone take that
candle I don't have anything for that
can you close this door I can't really
see what this stuff is
oh so that's how I turn on what how much
this thing goes away it's interesting
okay mmm tells us oh you should have put
that much in here I got an empty bucket
what is that oh it's alive weird
can't take them right I'm missing one
yes yes nope okay that's how you open
this okay well let me get a pen okay
let's do this let's find out how much
easier this stupid thing is not a
scandal quick
yeah like this one tell okay I got if I
have to try it away so
so triangles three triangles three
ooh I know what she says okay plus
equals one
wait now I got to find what this is for
okay it is um putt sweetly equals five
okay perfect there we go
what three turay and fat ah the old
knife trick huh what the heck is that
they got water or blood to blood right
now right bucket with water
hey I was the knife that sucker
oh oh yeah somehow trap that thing okay
blood vodka Tabasco and a special
ingredient
yeah I got a mate kidding me
knife
I do the knife cut this
I have to get the eight
okay right now it's crap I don't even
know I just filled up with it okay no no
what the heck am i doing
oh I can tell what her to go okay five
and five and six if I had this six here
in this five year
well what I don't I can't wait six plus
five there we go
well I'm really messing up here
um
it might like return it
five goes in there now you have eleven
I'm missing something
can I cut this now
see it's missing this guy they were
supposed to go in there right now no one
supposed to go in there can't do
anything with that yeah see that one
waters missing
I can't put this in here honey empty
canteen that gets you it isn't that
bread Oh
can I put this in here
with the special ingredient is
nope nope nope nope
bring my Bloody Mary this has to do
something
Oh Oh
if this
okay
what the heck
tip with Tabasco in here is the second
use for this Tabasco I don't know what
it is though
nope
maybe I can use it to lower this guy
got him
well these plans
what is the link is their way down what
something water supplies my step there's
a race hatch planned hmm I trust you met
yet mr. dare can't leave the room until
he found some meat always have to kill
him Oh
oh how do I ever get that blood
excuse my heading it was Tabasco okay
and I got that blot you're sick psycho
think it's it
it's a special ingredient
that is a special ingredients
really strange
oh it's something with this okay five
goes here c5 in here now out there six
in here
eleven
five
one-five
five six
I'm Candace still 5 at 5:10 1 6 1 2 3 4
everybody get these guys
that's what three there
guys take this now
hmm
very strange
okay
uh-huh what now up okay
getting news me where's that
need to meet
[Music]
which I need this again
it's definitely this chemistry set
yes okay
what is this he just deleted a water
it's so particular
what is that what's that making
something you can make here canteen I
don't know what it is but that checked
them off
huh
I know what that is doing now
there's a bug up there
okay it was check we just click around
extinguish this that's it here and this
in here nothing okay
um you had to get like sauce or
something
no absolutely no sauce
that's weird I don't know what that is
Basco that's the moth I need you see
this guy says I ain't different bring me
a Bloody Mary
hmm there's one of those key things
mr. dears key okay
No thank you my said I what did you just
move over didn't moved in it
how examine isn't ya just moving this
whole thing shifting a little bit that's
weird
how you get stupid guy wait I'm gonna go
ride this class you can't do this thing
you help someone not stoop Tabasco okay
okay should I can't put the last hi
oh okay I don't know why it didn't work
before um Sutton it is is that no it's
probably this one okay sit here
you like that don't you
yeah I like that that's been missing are
you ready yet
very perplexing is there a pattern here
it's got a pattern here
yep here it is okay yes okay interesting
interesting
okay yes this is is this attack
Oh see okay I think right now with the
day with us I think right now what the
day what does get out of here and come
back that's e that guy is just like the
ingredient
pause and s says perfect hips
yeah I can't perfect
just want that back down all right hey
it is complete no just kidding
yeah perfect just want that sakta all
right
yeah resto de hey you got budding drank
up for dad I uh has a taste
yeah I could taste bunny you know I
can't drink up drink up come on I know
yeah I getting at the dammit and they're
done
okay da la me so sad hmm okay what's
different
hey you ready for my photo shot of
course that I have Kass
Oh mr. Barton I'm so hungry okay oh
hello I need you to run my bath tonight
and yeah bad I will miss I betcha mr.
rabbit I know you're a stone-cold killer
anything iron oh hello sir
dare I that nice a Saturday no okay um
this was the dears guess I just can't do
that
yeah you can't visit rooms at data okay
well let's just see what's going on here
Traverse a nice dinner oh this is um the
key to they got the dear guy that's just
odd there we go yep okay I got your
stupid ingredients I want to get the
mushrooms well yeah yeah yeah no I can't
go upstairs so it has to be here right
you like that mr. crow this I can
actually click on anything here sir
sir I know ya got the mushrooms I know
yeah I got them
mm-hmm mm-hmm mushrooms where are the
mushrooms and now yeah got my shams in
here I know that not no no no birthday
had kinda mushrooms
I haven't got anything with this house
and not pass
okay all right let's cut this hair like
that
mister you like that don't ya
that first dinner oh just perfect
everyone's like now we're having dare
but where's miss Ted they're almost
perfect to practice ending at the
mushrooms that falls the guests go to
their rooms correct sound Ava I lack in
my packet yeah uh-huh yeah we're habits
do with carrots and white beans okay I
need to get the white beans so she can
help the gas and the rooms No
need some fresh meat for tomorrow sorry
about where's the white pants where is
the white pants
yes I got nothing here
what's this antenna at nighttime right
yeah yeah and I guess that's time you
sure
yeah a nap-nap
I can't kill into this guy's room
anymore Kenny he's no longer with us
okay what did we need oh crap
mr. borer yes that bore reps are gonna
think at hell I was never born mm-hmm
buy me a sandwich oh you're so
gluttonous huh hey cute me can I help
you
the hell is this
I'll take this lattice thank you I guess
we really gotta make it worse ang but
the lights right there [ __ ] and care
perfect
put it on here that's disgusting how
would you like trading all these people
iCarly what toilet paper no I prize to
make it like this thing all blues and
reds and I can let me get the news at me
now okay okay okay okay okay oh thank
you so much texted me I think okay I got
an opium pipe perfect
there was two masters are formed by our
mutual friend about your addictions
anxieties I want to invite you to rusty
like are excellent mental health and
fishing facility any distress this job
ok I can remember this one just like a
forest locked so typical now happy I'm
perfect
okay yeah want this yeah right get low
like that
hey like that you like that
Oh arms getting smoky camera it's a
straight oh my god sorry
so it's a Claddagh here what have I done
we got tear smog a way smoked how much
this time where are you I missed a crowd
yeah
perfect happy that I care [ __ ] sandwich
and I lie yeah you like it you like a
taste of that already go
I'll ask my chance
take this off that's so gross so gross
well why isn't here Eddie someone's
right
you like sabotage us but this instead oh
I gotta give him Toby Raleigh
[Music]
I'm a sandwich
what the heck dad
kappa the knife in there
take everything
this is doubt how do you it's gotta be
an order
Kenny living here
[Music]
oh that's in there a lot of cattle in
here
I can't my plan
maybe there's a oh okay maybe I do the
opposite if I want to get unlocking you
know the other door
Avenue
weird
hey smoked are they uh Pam Oh what is
this
hahaha let me get it let me get low
again kind of get it that low before
because
there's definitely like a weird limit me
as fresh boobies real quick
okay
çf make us go a lot lower
can I take this off
camping this came out they're gonna say
when I saw this about it just like a
circle is what is compound
see I guess I'm it's it's wrong maybe
I'd make him do this I have no idea what
I just did
okay this game is completely random to
dark up okay blues you're all on the
right side
I heard you like bacon and hey let back
in
eat
oh whatever they did
ah they'll hammer track come on bro come
on bro ah yes yes hey it's all right
back
that's disgusting and really is gross
and I got the red wine and tomatoes I
really messed that one out
sorry I gotta meet this thing real quick
things going
okay yeah oh yeah see that was him I
still need bread wine and tomatoes she
assured wine how do I get that red want
magic track
I have no idea I got that [ __ ] tomatoes
yeah sure
get tasty tasting
perfect
oh yeah like that how you like that time
yeah once died yeah AVO yeah well I can
thank you is this one
hello sir
whoa what's going on here
did I once a that house the nice eh
are there
is he a bad I say yes
[Music]
okay I got the optional potatoes so I
should probably get the pigeon then
Wayne yeah what is that
yeah arrests jealous okay I won't leave
the betcha it's hard for half at our
shop
iris pheasant Jennifer please take my
picture you know I will
yeah I found music and another safe pair
of X and just perfect macht take the
matches
rediff angley's and a fresh and King
okay
something is missing thank you
what is it
ha
hey I'm red alright hello red
okay lady in blue is this cross it mr.
Allens like this don't know what to have
that man's
what is that can't guess time
yes
yeah paper try glass plant that guy says
she's a canoeing see he's thinking
fighting them all for like different
reasons he said I could murder them
great I don't know what that is
no lady in blue so it's like that okay
honey why can't I do it like oh it's
like one per line that correct that's a
correct
okay
yeah that perfect now what's going that
light
sounded funny though that light
something is missing now then we're
doing weapon
I think is that sir
what
okay it says that
Wow this is so weird it's a word one
Oh
that's perfect now
what the heck okay wait circle pyramid s
I'm asked not the ink hey gay but this I
that yeah I can't it's something else we
got a deal
mr. crows like this
oops
oops
sorry I messed that one up
can't kapha careful
perfect
okay I got my pepper
ah mr. Crowl
okay there's how do I get what your
house mask I gotta get these guys to go
through the thing
how many like we had a father but you're
just not ready
yeah that's not ready for the spotlight
you know can I use this honor
is there something like the paintings no
no mr. crows painting
Oh nude fine last says its she's 3:30
yeah Matt come on small rolling pin
yeah
up
smile acts
what is that it's my touch
okay okay mr. Wow
let me just see what this okay okay I
know I'm gonna get look crazy hair about
perfect okay yeah we go yes mr. Howell
has she done here then that everything
you want I just take my picture
let's go what's going on with this one
no there's zigzag yeah
holy crap okay wait four dots left what
two three four one two one two three
okay
I'm two three four so there we go
play all right now that's not what I
drew all right this it's my Jepson okay
yeah what happened that would keep
opt-out okay let's see what this says
part of the murder weapon no your bet
what the heck let's take my picture oh
she thinks to take a photo
interesting
okay and they're done ah
again I think this was a kayaking person
yeah
that's right one yeah is there a certain
order to dum tss yeah you go
okay down sack
and as I get
any like fast you like fast that I got
stock hey a stock again
disgusting
and I know
nothing
Sam out time out okay what kind of Mac
we rabbit legs and white beans okay I
guess go for the rabbit and I know if
you guys ever played that the Sheep
escaped games but one of them was
birthday party and the rabbits just like
shits up everyone just a rabbit uh yes
ah ah much class like okay I'm watching
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
annalee so that was just texting okay um
tag I said I'm it at this this isn't my
packet it's that buzzing like crazy okay
yeah
DNA this I sir I can't play this game -
all right yep the head too
great triangle stone
no symbols on them
like the two was where I think two is a
look at that wrist again
it was unlike a double-sided flower
right there
king goes with the tiara out looking
thing crap which one was that varies
whereas a cow I don't know I'll put in
the corner five what date the fire I
can't remember
nope
five is looks like a French floor delay
okay I'm gonna take cut out
but that's the evil rabbit oh my god I
say yeah I say yeah
let's picture out this that's a food
picture
what time are my ass
there is this
I'll get that right
that's weird not know what this is
yes is
it looks similar to go in the box it's
in here
okay what is a Skoda ace is like that
double-sided like spear think
I'd say there are so let's see what
happens
I can't Bradley backwards head something
magic I bend and I was too calm bow
okay I think it's just one kid like many
Heiner open this today
can't take this kind of okay
wait that's right I know
miss Estelle okay we gotta clear the
room we see back with a sword in here
now
get up with the head on the rabbit Oh
what's the order purple red white
[Music]
right
okay
get you okay um these are running out of
things here okay
get you sicker get you okay maybe the
ring goes in this box I think at the
last king oops
oh it's yeah I can huh
hey suppose we got here right
what back up high well play okay
perfect everyone lobby yeah yeah I guess
hey Dad
yeah I mean you're mad that I for sure
is for sure what was it yep
here's this
okay
how do I like this better wait wonder
where everyone went
very sad very sad what's happening here
test ours that's perfect almost
can I get that smile a spin look weird
no
this looks so suspicious he black bears
say hey black bears are there
yes I did black bag
like anti-black pass can't remember that
gun it yeah okay that makes a is a mess
pageant type I met at Bayview get my sim
card
you ain't got it wait a how she has got
thighs for sure yeah great looks highly
technical okay
I wonder why she will be taking a bath
like this in such a crazy place but you
know that's not my problem
you know hello mr. Pratt off
but imagine I ended up okay
we have the day pitch in it okay all
right I don't know what that towers got
[Music]
that guy she's the turkey that's fine
now let me solve this thing okay bad dad
dad angles five deaths of nine regiments
at my calculations are correct I get
that
Plus st. goes far as - jegos tell so
that masked man okay this is for like a
triangle equals one then we'd squared
equals 3 that means this squiggly equals
6
and I meet the S equals 8 okay some
simple math okay some sample okay this
is ain't it squiggly sex 1 and 3 hello
there didn't expect to see you so soon
must be kind of embarrassing that I here
[Music]
okay but this here
[Music]
[Music]
idiot and some cane which is exactly I
want the doctor ordered
hey like that car he like that okay
panic just kidding
I feel like an act but not tight I am no
jesús shot goes that to make white cube
tell that I think I saw patter there's
some weird pattern okay fit like a
sideways version on one too
make second ahem
okay you just keep this thing in
okay
you must think we're so stupid mr.
battle now nope oh please
[Music]
he's pretty good
forget this better
[Music]
I catch it rat
how does it feel to be in my my snare
little one how does that fell debase our
hapless
[Music]
guys let's go oh can looks like we're
doing get and you get this stay down now
tell me cowboy I haven't figured out yet
oh wait
this think by tells me Dan had that
okay
perfect all right you're lucky dad
little little whatever you are right not
so fast
[Music]
where'd he go
that is my job
yes an add-on well Sam Makani and the
blueberries I'm gonna punch and this if
they get him in like a certain order but
all right you would have known that
answer guys
no I don't listen guys tonight okay
okay
married I was any mr. Howell
dinner
variable
one's a negative one yeah Mr Al ah well
there we are
the last dinner yes thank you for all
the memories and Harvey I'm really glad
you brought the cigar that Pam Blake
will be grateful take a look at the
black queues would you sure better yeah
explain a damn presser alright uh keep
that up perfect
- that before
and it there
and the eora
attention okay
a centrosome not only the key to the
past it's also to the future
[Music]
what's going on here I'm adding antic
ass
[Music]
I must I have a
okay
ah I say now to bake and tenured wow
that's a really good game really fun um
cup Bell enjoyed and thank you